hey poppy here it's Papa John and you're
listening to the h3 podcast go Ethan go
ela well well looks like we've got an
official spokesman papa was looking for
a job and we scooped him up welcome
everybody as Papa said to the h3 podcast
today's episode is sponsored by hims
PewDiePie was supposed to be on today's
episode he couldn't make it so we have
no PewDiePie but hopefully we are enough
for you all the way but was it really
Papa JAMA Tuesday it feels like it was
so long ago
yeah it was Monday and early too that's
why now Papa came in he saw he conquered
it was a beautiful moment I mean we have
to talk about that I felt I mean people
said I ruined the interview there was a
lot of harsh criticism for me but I'm
used to that I feel like our fans
there's the Rotem it's like I'm destined
to be hated by my fans it's just part of
the game now I've accepted it people
saying I interrupted too much actually I
got a lot of heat for Sean Evans for
interrupting - yeah but I have a theory
I have a I have a method you know I'm
trying a new interviewing style and
although it's not perfect I think that
it's um I think it's it's going to be
great to hone and get better at and
basically it's I'm B I'm definitely
being more aggressive
you know I use at first I had a real
problem with inner with interrupting
people like in the beginning of our show
and then I learned to not interrupt
people and give them their space but
then I felt like I was out of control I
didn't have control the show and
sometimes they just people can have a
tendency to go on and on about things
that either I've heard them talking
about already I know what they're gonna
say or they're just doing let PR right
and I and for me we have finite time in
here
and I want to get to the meat to
something I want to get to the heart of
something and yourself getting bored
sometimes wait if it doesn't go in the
direction that you want it to go I don't
want to say bored not bored but like
that but I want to what I want to do is
go to a deeper level yeah
and so it's kind of a tough balancing at
because on one hand you want your guests
to be as comfortable as possible because
that will that will ultimately help them
getting to a deeper level at the same
time we have two hours here and I if
they go like start talking about stuff
like flour Lea language I just I don't
really I feel like as an interviewer I
want to not have patient not you know I
don't want to hear things that I don't
consider meat like if they're saying
something and I know exactly what
they're saying I don't want to I don't
necessarily want to hear and I assume
that you guys I'm assuming you guys know
exactly what they're saying - so let's
find out let's find out what what's
going on like with um you know but
that's fine I'm used to taking the heat
now love/hate right mostly hate these
days no that's not true no but but I I'm
aware so I am being more aggressive I'm
trying to take more control and I
personally like it I think it's I'm
trying to develop a unique style of
interviewing instead of just I don't
really I'm gonna try being passed from
giving people space and it's fine but I
feel like we can elevate it and have our
own unique style of interviewing and
that's what I'm trying to develop it so
while it might not be pleasant to watch
and at times awkward and uncomfortable
and you think to yourself wow Ethan is
the worst interview of all time which I
saw that comment so many times I would
like to see you come in here and try to
hold a conversation that's yeah mother
well they didn't say they're great
interviewers and I'm not saying I'm a
great interview all I'm saying is that
maybe not being a great interviewer
makes you a great interviewer think
about it I would like to express that I
feel like I know where you are going for
and I
supported because I think what we kind
of shared the same view and we a lot of
times we'll have the same experience
because we sit here together so after a
few guests where we were more passive we
kind of feel like it's just not
satisfying we didn't go didn't get to
the meat of what we wanted no getting
there do anything they brought out there
was I had like these really weird ones
where it's like I had a guest and I felt
so out of control I had no control of
the dialogue the pacing that kept going
on and on about things that I that I
thought were repetitive mm-hmm that I I
wanted to get to something else and and
then the comments are like wow the h3
podcast has really come into its own
Ethan was amazing inner joy and I would
read those and be like I thought I'd
totally [ __ ] cool with that I was
totally out of control felt awful so I
don't know what to say but I have to
ultimately follow my own instincts here
yeah so it's I think it's a work in
progress that it's tough because
everyone get to watch you know
everyone's watching you trying stuff so
but it's fine like I said I'm used to
those comments don't bother me you know
ultimately those both those episodes
were were well-received
despite everyone saying I'm the worst
interviewer at least the guests were
happy with that's right their appearance
and how they were perceived which is to
me is really important to the win I want
to make sure the guest is happy I don't
want to win I want them to leave and
feel like I should have never gone on
that show so because look at the
comments pop up who's a who's a divisive
figure controversial figure everyone
came out hating me and loving pop I mean
that's an incredible feat my own fans no
less so I consider that a big winner you
know Papa even Papa's like my new Papa
bawling ela walks in because is that I
was pop Pop's on the phone we've been
calling I don't even know you got a Papa
figure yeah I have a mother figure
I wonder if he could be like a business
mentor I feel like I could call and ask
business questions for teddy fresh and
stuff I wonder if someone like him gets
it all the time though and it's annoying
you know well I don't have any logic
uestions firm but when I do when I have
like him you know
I need like a seasoned businessman well
at any rate it's funny even Papa called
me he was like you're he's like
everybody loves me he's like you're
taking some heat in the comments though
like I know Papa my fans don't like that
yeah I love that too the great sound way
well you know as we were sitting here
and talking to him I kept having
flashbacks to us in Israel just like our
first videos about him and I was like if
you told me that in a few years this
will be ice I would have never believed
it's awesome it's like it's so insane
I'm caught on the phone with Papa he
called me when YouTube I'll get to that
but youtube like removed it from
trending and D monetize it because they
thought there was a racial slur in it
which is so stupid and ironic we'll get
to that but Papa calls me he's like how
many views do we lose this is outrageous
it's a conspiracy I was like I know Papa
D but he got he did great and he wanted
to help
right it was like can my boy yeah he was
like oh my people do we do Papa I got
this one out of control you got you're
dating I got the YouTube don't worry
I don't know I isn't it nice to watch an
interview where it's a little well
immediately I'm not that I'm not great
at this style of interviewing that's
this more aggressive form of
interviewing and controlling the
narrative but it's gotta be I mean for
me at least I find it more interesting
because it kind of reminds me like a lot
of times when we made guests outside of
the show we'll have a really interesting
exciting conversation and then on the
show it's like okay now I'm going to
give you
like the PR and say exactly the stuff
that I have to be like guided and or
guarded and say it like in a guarded way
yeah so I feel like what you're going
for with this direction is gonna
hopefully rattle some more truth out of
them yeah it's more like the real
conversation yeah and by the way I mean
people like oh I can't they're just so
rude to him you you I can't believe
you're asking about dating it's like
Hello
that's [ __ ] interesting [ __ ] like
like I can get it like Papa wants to
come on here and do the PR and talk
about like it's all it's about the main
ingredients is people all right it's
like dude I don't want this I don't like
I want to hear about your dating I want
to hear
who-who's Papa putting his whose pizza
whose pizza whose oven is his pizza
going in do you know what I'm saying
that's good that was rude Ethan can i
interject if just yes what do you think
then I I agree I appreciate that you're
this new thing that you're trying and to
get to the to the meat of people's
answers a little bit more the whole
thing with asking about his divorce
maybe came a little early in the
interview well again I'm not I'm not
great at it right yeah and I like kind
of thing you know once he's settled in a
little bit more comfortable you might
have even gotten a better answer for
that question well that may have been
better after the pizza eating right well
again i I didn't anticipate that being I
didn't realize it was so soon either so
I didn't realize it was such an awkward
thing but you know [ __ ] it let's make it
awkward you're not here just enjoy it
man you know what I'm saying just enjoy
the ride yeah but we're not rude but it
was great now we're best friends he
calls me every day how dare you say that
we read anyway you know that's happened
with a few guests where people people
get offended on their behalf but the
reality is like they're not offended
like they're fine
Papa's calling you every day it's like
he's he's not upset about it
but I think anyway I don't care but I
think yeah but I think it's good
obviously I'm better like I have a hard
time opening interviews cuz it's really
hard to pick the right topic words like
yeah I want to talk about something
relevant I want it to be light-hearted
and fun and relax them and I want to be
interesting too but yeah I feel like it
always gets better later in the
interview so it's just because I think
the guest is more comfortable yeah but
that's just the nature of being here is
he like at first he was he was super
shut up he was like I was like hey papa
he's like hey glad to be here but then
at the end you know he opens up he's
more comfortable on camera because it's
a look you come in here as a guest it's
a very intense you got all these cameras
you've never been in this you're sitting
across from me who you know is gonna
give you a hard time in Papa's case you
know you know he was expecting some jabs
for sure he's never done this before
he's sitting there you know so yeah I
understand that the nervousness so it's
a tough act to is a hard balancing act
Bobby but yeah obviously the divorce
thing didn't hit perfectly but whatever
it's all good - I thought it was funny
when you asked him if he's getting any
weird ass but he kind of it but is great
because I mean it sounded like he is
because he didn't say no or add any
finger antibiotic he was very romantic
yeah he didn't say no and he also well
anyway Popat blah chop pop a blast Papa
John people how do you disrespect Papa
John it's like what anyway here's a
comment actually if I can continue to
praise myself people who at with 41
votes after 22 I already want so here's
a comment in support of me the podcast
is getting too much hate I just noticed
how much hate you think off for the Sean
Evans podcast because interrupting and
asking two personal questions
it's just me but I think it was one of
the most entertaining podcasts yet I
feel like Ethan is just finding a very
unique hilarious interview style but
cutting the usual fake friendly
interview BS it's making it awkward he's
like the opposite of Jimmy Fallon I like
it I like it I agree with you with the
exception of him - Scott oh come on I
thought the top comment was more
agreeable with the disc with the
exception of discussing Papa's dating
life poor Papa's a wholesome guy for
months fresh off divorce hard cringe
well okay fine
what is he we can discuss it he can say
what he wants what about allowed to ask
the guy I don't regret asking him he's
[ __ ] awesome and it made everyone
uncomfortable that's fine
nothing wrong with that you know that
comment says it's refreshing oh yeah
that's the one I wanted to read until
this guy snuck his way up to the top I
agree the way they interview is
refreshing it's a little more raw if you
know what I mean
oh I know what you mean baby they aren't
afraid get raw I like it raw we like it
raw here they aren't afraid to ask
questions and I think at least a much
more interesting interviews oh here
here's one so here's one who hates me
yeah or maybe not I'm just gonna read it
for the sake since we're here already I
feel like every hate comment is an
attempt at showing Ethan the light that
as viewers we think he's craving and
we're doing this in the form of bad rude
advice I agree though in the end they're
my favorite people to view and listen to
but he agrees that they're trying to
show me the light which item not sure
what the light is damn bro juice I just
really want you thing to be happy and
making moves with the power of his
platform we got to stop being so toxic
thank well that's the sweet guy yeah but
I can't tell what his what the light is
he wants me just like um I think what
he's saying is that he has some
criticism but he doesn't want to hurt
your feelings with those toxic comments
I am sensitive but that being said I am
okay with it everyone is sensitive
anyone who's not saying that it's not is
lying you every guess that we have on
goes to
same thing it's like there's no such
thing as not being sensitive thank you
that being said the episode has a 98%
like so could have been that bad but but
um going into this you know there's two
ways to react to it it's like oh I'm
just gonna go back to the way I was
because everybody hates this and hates
me
or I can just buckle down know that I'm
gonna get hate because people don't
quite maybe I'm not just not good at it
or maybe people aren't used to it and
just get better at it because ultimately
I feel like I'm gonna be delivering a
more interesting better product and I'm
gonna be more fulfilled and engaged here
as an interviewer so inch in summary am
I the worst interviewer of all time
maybe but does that by itself make me
interesting I think so
so it's a race to the bottom and I hope
you'll join me the balance out there
doing his thing no you don't want maybe
you do but founds already out there for
you but let's talk more about the pop of
follow up here's an here's a headline or
an album of all the headlines now you
know Bobby Jon came on the show and I
think he's talked about a lot of
interesting things he talked about being
extorted blackmailed a conspiracy to out
him from the company and yet all the all
the freaking headlines are the same Papa
John's founder I didn't eat 40 pizzas
and third days I had 40 pizzas how was
it the headline this is stupid
Oh Papa John admits he didn't actually
eat 40 pizzas I can believe that that is
the headline Papa John founder reveals
the truth he didn't really eat 40 pizzas
in 30 days and they all chose that and
it's shocking there's the best one here
right it's uh-oh this is the best one
Papa John reveals that he lied to
America he didn't actually eat 40 pizzas
in 30 days you
[ __ ] lied to the whole country
I thought this was like no or the
interview I I thought that I was losing
my mind like how is this the headline
and I asked some people downstairs who
listened to it like Andrew okay and he
listened to the podcast and he said he
had the same reaction because it was
like there's some meat there right he
said you ate 40 pizzas no he was oh that
was the right way back another but I
called him out on that too right yeah I
was like dude that means yeah you had 40
pizzas the article it's just a stupid I
mean this is an incredible story by the
way yeah he's a designer great guy but
to me it seems like one of those
sentences that are obviously kind of
like you just late you don't mean it
literally eat 40 pieces in 30 days it's
not humanly possible if I like by the
third day of eating Pete's in a row like
that I think my skin was started to fall
off my body
but some of the articles were like yet
the host h3 called him out oh and didn't
let it slide had meat eating even Klein
said hard-hitting journalist good about
that take that Newsweek oh and then and
then Papa Schnatter
after the day after our podcast sold
another huge chunk so I was like what
I wonder that's Papa just made 63
million that's a good fold 1 million
shares at $63 24 cents and made 63
million dollars the day after our
podcast so hey not a bad week for Papa a
turns me on
mmm nice but what did he say that about
in context something about a good pizza
probably certainly not about data wasn't
weird-ass know that turns me on
it was it over busy
no sir about pizza I can't remember yeah
good for Papa he still owns 1.8 million
shares man that's a lot of money that
kind of riches [ __ ] you know it's crazy
Papa is like we can't even comprehend
how rich he is yet like Michael
Bloomberg who I'm seeing his ads this
guy I don't think there's ever been a
media buy like this in the history of
humankind
yet he he's like the 10th richest guy in
the world he's got like like 50 billion
or something like that guys closer to 16
yeah like 60 billion Papa doesn't have 1
billion it's close but Bloomberg closer
to a billion than half and the words of
the great papa
but Bloomberg 60 billion he has 60 times
more wealth but is not just throwing it
all away like is there it has no chance
does he dude he's point he's starting to
pull really well pretty good in some
places going up like because you got you
may as may have seen that he did all
these mean buys he bought it had all
these main pages which was just
outrageous which we'll talk about that
but he's like getting me everywhere he's
on TV
he's on YouTube he's on the radio he's
on the main pages he's every fact I'm
surprised he's not like on airplanes
outside like trailing behind airplanes
that's the last frontier it's the air
yeah I just sent you a breakdown of his
ad spending he's spent almost three
times as much as all of the other
candidates combined on advertising
including Trump not just the other
Democrats including Trump and all the
other Democrats he's spent three times
as much of this has an unlimited budget
that's something like 300 million
dollars which is almost which is like
which is let's say half of Papa John's
worth that is like 100 bucks to
Bloomberg that's all just on media Buy
yeah in the last quarter we should all
go go into that business like that's
what I'm saying meeting every every day
for years these [ __ ] media companies
are just making so much money from this
[ __ ] you know like I donated a thousand
dollars to Bernie Sanders and endorsed
him and I and I was like just gonna go
to buying commercials because ultimately
is just paying more rich people is that
a problem
damn go ahead I mean who knows where the
dollars your specific dollars are gonna
go but I mean there's also campaign
staff and Canvassers and there's a lot
of things besides advertising but yeah I
mean but at least some percentage of it
is gonna go to an ad company sure but at
least Sanders is actually by funded by
people right so it's poor people
funneling all their money to rich ass
media companies no well it's not like
data guys who get like millions from the
Koch brothers or whatever the [ __ ]
brothers yeah Bloomberg funded by people
to just one person people people well at
least I don't have to give him money
[ __ ] at least he can buy his own ads how
much money do people spend I say hating
to they say people saying that is like a
defense of him is like oh well he's just
spending his own money so he's not
beholden to anybody and it's like yeah
exactly he's not beholding to you like
well the money doesn't have to do with
that the president I mean I'm assuming
most presidents aren't there to I don't
mean it in the sense of making money no
but but that but because he's rich
doesn't mean that he's not beholding to
the constituents I mean he's the same
duty as any president I mean on paper
you're right yeah I see people wondering
if he should be allowed to spend this
much on on campaigning well you get the
best in my in my opinion the best
counterpoint and that he said look
advertising is only effective to a point
yeah and then as a point it just becomes
annoying so so you know yeah he's a bit
he's a rich guy that's how that's how it
works you can buy advertising but
look ultimately Bloomberg does have
experience so he's gonna do better than
a guy like Steuer who's like who the
[ __ ] is this guy I mean he was the mayor
of New York okay that story is just like
I didn't know her like why why are you
even on the stage at all I can talk
about steyr yeah whatever thumps -
whatever [ __ ] that guy what has he done
he's just a rich dude I don't know he's
night power does so many rich people
they're not that are running they all
just one billionaire he's like hey I'm
running he's on the stage but
Bloomberg's ads are actually story
stores his that sucked he's because he
has no charisma he's like I I think
Donald Trump is I'm the only candidate
that thinks that climate changes our
number-one concern but but Bloomberg
actually is smart because he's he's not
charismatic guy and he's not really like
impressive looking so he's not in his
ads he does like hate jobs on Trump he
does jobs about he I've seen commercials
about gun control he doesn't even show
his face he just goes I'm uncle
Bloomberg and I in horses he doesn't
mean shows face just his voice I mean
that's smart that is smart he knows he's
got the bet yeah actually he's gonna get
on the stage and I think when people see
him I don't think I think you're
probably gonna be like this is Bloomberg
I really do actually I don't know what
he looks like even I mean I do look thin
him but I don't really know like I
haven't seen him you know on the debates
so I don't know but Trump calls him low
mic cuz he's short
oh he's short see I do know that he
guess how tall is low five eight
it's short for a presidential candidate
I mean I mean it's a weird thing but all
presidents are generally it's not like
they stop to be but the reality is
almost all president like just
throughout history presidents are on
average taller than short presidents in
Israel George Bush wasn't tall was he
w
Yahoo's not that tall Oh same kids that
talk about America here like our tall
men here well how tall was George Bush w
or senior both let's see George W Bush
is six feet tall now is six and his dad
seniors height is six - but we now we
had someone that was 5-7 little [ __ ]
Trump I think it's like six - Clinton is
six - Anders is six feet
Sanders is tall Wow even at his age no
he's probably Reagan was six one thing
hang on hang on hang on
keep going we're gonna punish for
president who was Teddy Roosevelt Eddie
Roosevelt I don't think he was a tall
guy he was alphas [ __ ] though Klobuchar
is 5'4
that's true Teddy Roosevelt was only 510
this is an article Amy Klobuchar five
feet four inches is a pretty good size
for a president okay so we went back to
Teddy Rowe that it was 510 but people
were shorter back in the day so you know
that may have still been a door above
average what do you make of that I think
it's like a weird primal thing that we
look to our leaders to be big people
I like a weird outfit yeah weird yeah I
don't know lame we're so lame we got a
smashed the shortest president was James
Madison who was only 5'4 but that was
like one of the first yeah Madison was
like what back then or Munchkins back
then oh you know what's interesting
George Washington was like super tall
for that he was like six - back then
that was like a giant this day let's see
George Washington's height whatever I'm
gonna let me down it's not coming up
with I remember reading that George
Washington was of unusually large
stature giving me all of these
elevations for the city of Washington -
inches Oh
that's huge back or how much do you know
six - six - but back then the story yeah
that would be here it's a six four I
think you know the six four is like
Abraham Lincoln was six four I believe
that's true actually he was really tall
he's exceptionally tall yeah it's a
weird thing I don't know but there have
been very few short presents this is the
average height of the first 44 presence
is 5 foot 11 inches yeah which I think
would be above the average America
that's how tall I am
can I be President he just barely made
the cut dude you're in I wonder if you
just 2024 wonder if taller dudes have
that like when you're like tall like
that tall like 6 - maybe you are like
more confident or more aggressive I
don't know yeah I think it just plays
into the psychology and like I think
it's how people perceive you but that
probably has an effect on them - mm-hmm
I would never want to be President what
a nightmare but so beat it mayor Pete
I'm sure you can never win short yes
that's really interesting I feel like he
can't win he's a little man same with
Mike Bloomberg
it's got to be Bernie because it is a 5
foot 8 same as Bloomberg there you go
little Pete a little it is not that
short
is it 5/8 is what I mean
maybe slightly below average but
slightly because I'm used to meter so
maybe it's like I'm not like for example
I would say my my dad is probably 5/8 I
mean the average Americans Heights and
American man's height is 5 foot 10
inches so there you go
so both Bloomberg and Buddha ginger
below below average lame anyway back to
the Papa John we're actually at 30
minutes if you want to go to break all
right let's do that down so Papa throw
it to break we should have got a break
oh this is Papa John and we'll be right
back
next time get them record them on the
next phone call all right we'll be right
back
66% of men start losing their hair by
age 35 and once you've noticed it
thinning it's already too late as that
hairline slowly starting to move
backwards do you have any bald spots yet
who you starting to sweat getting
worried well guess what
the best way to prevent more hair loss
is to do something about it while you've
got some left it's time to grab the New
Year by the [ __ ] o follicles Cisco
follicles by the balls
grab it well however you can here's to a
new year of personal growth why do guys
turn to weird solutions or do nothing
when they can turn to medical medicine
and science to keep the beautiful hair
on your head that's for hems calm it's a
one-stop shop for hair loss skin care
sexual wellness for men it's time to
write a new chapter one in which you
have heir note this is not snake oil
this is not a gas station counter
supplement with like a with like a
hologram on it you know those this is
real stuff there's some weird stuff at
the gas station with Holograms on it you
wear those Holograms you know what I'm
talking about then I do okay thank you I
just want to make sure I wasn't talking
into the void prescription solutions
these are backed by science guys there's
no more awkward in-person doctor visits
or long pharmacy lines for hems connects
you with real doctors online which could
save you hours it's completely
confidential indiscreet you're always
going to get you are going to answer a
few quick questions a doctor will review
and they will determine if it's right
for you and they can prescribe you the
medicine to treat the hair loss that's
shipped directly to your door this
holiday season let it grow let it grow
let it grow with hims
dive into 20/20 hair first
[Music]
I have a hard time imagining that
because it sounds like you're falling on
your head yeah you're just like trying
to commit suicide or something you're
just but okay they say dive into 2020
here first if I die at least I got hair
right now my listeners can get started
with their first month for free that's
right go to for hanscom's slash h3
that's for hems calm slash h3
prescription wires an online
consultation with a physician who will
determine if a prescription is
appropriate off the belt only prescribed
three months minimum subscription
additional restriction applied see
website for full details and important
safety information
remember that's for hems kong slash
nature you got to love this [ __ ] it says
disclaimer must include what am i a
lawyer
[Music]
alright well there you go for hems
there's a big just so you know there's a
big disclaimer and yellow so take this
with a grain of salt I guess
welcome back we're talking about Papa
John now my favorite moment has
definitely got to be this moment here
actually I got to pull up the clip
because there was an uncut harp shaped
pizza and we were like man how do you
eat this so I just be smote at it and
folded it and threw it and then Papa
being the legend went in for his own
bite afterwards and I think that that
was probably my favorite moment are you
able to find a link to that to that
particular part of the episode I mean a
kindig-it of time Stan Oh approximately
where it is and then we've also got so
you know this is so weird that the I
like 3:00 a.m. the day we posted I'm on
YouTube looking at the stats and I go
and I noticed that the video was yellow
and it's removed from trending so I'm
like what what did what happened what do
we say you know and somebody sends me
this this screenshot and one of the
subtitles trying to pull it up here one
moment look at this so my rep at YouTube
said that it incorrectly heard Papa or
not Papa specifically but he said they
incorrectly heard a racial slur so when
a video here's a racial slur it gets
absolutely slammed the views tank
removed from trending no ads is awful
that has never happened to us and our
nearly 200 episodes ever the fact that I
happen to Papa John is so so bizarre
after everything he's been through
similar controversies and then here
laundry service no weren't I up to
something here well Papa was skeptical
but look but like I'm not gonna read it
but you it's it has papi here saying the
n-word which is by the way vegetables is
the auto caption yeah and I think the
auto caption
because they have Raiders review our two
hour-long podcast I don't know how
that's possible
I think the captions inform the reviewer
and then the reviewer goes and listens
and they're like oh yeah he said n-word
was everything I was like no not even
close
that would have been newsworthy what am
I talking about that not the 40 pizzas I
tell you but
so they got Papa's saying that and by
the way why are the captions displaying
the n-word unwrite answered that's like
our ASIS of YouTube its algorithm yeah
and I I've tried those captions a
million times
like the auto-generated ones I mean is
it ever usable like not forget accurate
like even usable in the slightest
like it's always nonsense it's just it's
gotten a lot better over over the time
has it okay
I do think so well before it just used
to be like word salad right but now like
if I'm watching something you know when
you're scroll over video and your home
page it will auto play without sound and
show subtitles so I've watched a
considerable amount of of a video with
just the subtitles so it has gotten
better I just can't believe that that
happened on to this guy who lost his
company over that word you know what
they have to I was like it must have
been removed after I reported it and
they fixed everything but here it is it
still here watch they got to be scrappy
and they got a [ __ ] though the food
whoa I said they got to take care of the
food yeah how would I not fixing it
yeah I don't know I mean they got to fix
the issue that they're auto-captions are
just saying the n-word dude does it
really make a really really good piece
you see it's good it's super accurate
you're going to invest you see any
mistakes Papa Joe we always wanted to be
not America's independence let's make
the best pizza right at Madison and we
were public we were a big company but we
always tried to act like a family-run
business with regards to do and that's
what the algorithm is pretty
racist dude that's so far and a hundred
percent accuracy yeah yeah here have to
they got to be scrappy and you got a
[ __ ] though the food is you know it's
funny it did sound like it though I
heard it there obviously you got to take
care there the rest of the sentence in
his configuration but that but if
somebody went and then listened just
like oh yeah he said the n-word [ __ ]
this video it's like you guys I saw the
flag there was an n-word yeah took one
look at it and saw it was Papa John
they're like oh yeah probably I don't
know but I do think somebody went and
listened and the racist ones I mean you
need more oversight like dude if you're
gonna say that my a reputable channel on
a two hour podcast and the Edward you
better listen to it twice
yeah you better we'll see what's the
content there's a big consequence huge
consequence but I it's funny cuz it
almost does sound like it which is funny
I do think that's and we were public we
were big company but we always tried to
act like a family-run business with
regards to people and product and that's
what the independents do they have to
they got to be scrappy and they got a
[ __ ] in the I think he slipped the
n-word in there no you obviously did it
but man I'm just saying you better go
double check I sent you that timestamp
video and discord by the way thank you
so here's my favorite so there's like a
whole pizza conspiracy
I said shoutout to you too for you know
screwing us over but then on the
subreddit enormous support the concedes
a conspiracy that blew me away
twenty thousand points people are
rallying around the pop up against pizza
conspiracy runs deep I agree they're so
quick to remove us from trending oh yeah
you know I'm finally there are we our
pockets are never there ever finally
gets there as a cool we're on trendy
three hours later no and any reason not
only is it off but our whole videos in
the doghouse you know I gotta tell you I
have a real I'm having a very a lot of
difficulties running the show here we
have a two hour long the chances that we
don't get [ __ ] for something in a two
hour long episode it's just it's caddis
it's like zero and it's just it's so
tedious you know if I was on television
if it was on radio if I was on streaming
than any other medium I wouldn't have to
contend with this [ __ ] and like they
want us to make shows they want a super
juice high quality content but they're
making us jump through the same hoops as
nobody's uploading videos for the first
time yeah you got to have a different
set of rules for us because I can't be
here and produce high quality content
for two hours what the conditions I have
I need somebody who's actually if if
you're gonna say that somebody on my
pocket said the N word and remove me
from trending and reduce my views
you better have someone double-check
that [ __ ] before you [ __ ] with me
because I'm not I'm I'm on here trying
to make high quality [ __ ] for your
platform
can you call this high quality well it
has a quality I mean I there's like
people I mean I get what you're saying
though because you know I'm the one
dealing with it with you most of the
time and yeah I mean it's it's it's a
surprise when we don't have an issue
with it at this point you know and you
know like Zak's been making these really
funny song parodies like of E and having
to pee like Ian's flow by Pearl Jam like
even flow and and I'm like these are so
great we're putting all this effort into
producing this great content yet if I
put it on the air we're not only gonna
get claimed we might get blocked
worldwide we might get DMC aid they're
gonna when I get claimed you can dispute
the content but they remove all the mid
rows
can turn the ads off I mean there's so
many ways in which I can get [ __ ] the
block worldwide they just take your
video down and you can't dispute it you
can't do anything oh is this gonna say
the block is just insane that that
shouldn't be an option I don't
understand I mean I don't know if the
fans understand but it's just it just
takes it down for everyone it's just
blocked and then it can it will be
blocked for a few days I've been
rallying on YouTube about that and I
think they're working on fixing that but
it's extraordinarily broken right now
because it's more powerful than a DMCA
takedown which is supposed to be the
ultimate form of removing content by
licence holders because it's a legal
document but youtube's given this tool
block worldwide there's no legal
consequence you don't have to fill out a
legal document it takes the video down
everywhere and I can't dispute it it
takes it stays down for three days so
it's more potent there's no
ramifications yes it's totally abusable
it's just the worst thing for creators
right now on the platform also if you're
talking about current events it can't
just be down for three days by the time
we'll be back up it's not real and it's
not our option and we have we have
sponsors we have a schedule I can I
can't go down for three days it's
outrageous so you end up cutting it you
end up not doing this you end up all the
sudden you're cutting all the [ __ ] and
all the sudden your show is just not
good it's not as good
yeah that's without anything to us we
have we keep having to cut stuff we have
a good idea they were like we can't do
that and then we have a segment we
removed the whole thing was we'd rather
not tell you no it's it's not it's not
right it's all right but I mean to look
also at the bright side there's no
bright side we do get to just work
ourselves there's no network to report
to or yeah but notes I mean right were
quit I guess but they are kind of giving
us notes and I do feel like at times are
more restrictive than any notes Network
and give us mm-hmm it's like it's stupid
and there's no feedback you're just kind
of like yeah there's no more you're
navigating through some [ __ ]
algorithm and like at least you're
talking to a human being there
worse right now it's worse there's no
there's no joy yellow how dare you try
to be optimistic where's the clip you
sent Dan I dropped it in our discord I
don't have discord open what oh here it
is Zach has gone today by the way he was
puking in the office
he brought his coronavirus here yeah and
he ins gone to skeleton crew
Ian's out with spalled card because
they're supposed to be fine Wednesday
are they doing a Valentine's Day pretty
epic that place axe having a beautiful
Valentine's Day cubed wife yeah they
went home he's a trouper though still
came in yeah yeah buzz he'll be like
well here's some alka-seltzer let's go
Sara's here the lovely Sarah pushed
yourself to the camera
oh right off thank you Sarah here is my
favorite moment from the Papa John we
can't rate this we got some replies
that's [ __ ] they should cut it like
n squares the four ventricles of the
heart yeah stupid [ __ ] yeah they
know not anatomy at all well I got a cut
somebody's got to cut it it's cool but
you still gotta cut we can't rate this
[Laughter]
that's a man of the people right there
beyond actually you know what the Papa
Diaz came and Ian liked it
he's like I'm a fan of the puppet yeah
he was well yeah like like fish burrito
I don't know he likes all the weird him
in burrito salmon burrito the psycho
field actually no it's funny we had
puppeteers we forgot to bring him out
but when we looked at him it's it's
actually it's nothing novel it's
literally just two slices closed in on
each other like it's really it was just
man we didn't really forget to bring it
out I just felt like it wasn't that
didn't tackle worthy I would have liked
to get his his in person to I also felt
bad because it was a day old yeah I had
ordered them didn't really want him to
try that that wouldn't be very fair yeah
here's the I thought this was
interesting because I went to analytics
I noticed that our views were like
flatlining like the views were just
really flatlining when when it went
yellow so here you can see it got
classified as saying the n-word and the
views are basically about to taper off
to nothing then here they fix it and it
takes off again so it was really about
to flatline to nothing I feel like this
graph is not looking that bad dude this
it doesn't look bad cuz they fixed it
fast
but if they didn't they sort of flatline
to nothing but there's no explanation
for why this dip this like heavy curve
here I mean to me that's like it doesn't
look that bad but I'm just saying if
this one for another day it would be
like flat we would have missed our
opportunity to get views but it was able
to recover because they responded
quickly so at least that I am grateful
that YouTube was able to fix it quick
enough um here's a great little video
edit you guys might enjoy a fan-made
this I heard I heard rumors that the
phones made by status array on YouTube
deep cutting power is we don't call for
example you got a copy of that is that
true yes
does it exonerate you yeah so yeah can
we hear it I don't know if you can hear
it uh the company of our myself didn't
have the tape volunteer service had the
tape the company got the tape within 10
days but they wouldn't let me hear the
call the tape until the next year here's
the beautiful thing is the there's a
tape for Medicine College on that speech
which is you can get that tape if you
want to see it I'll send ela the
transcript 2017 thank God they got a
tape because I knew what I said was not
that was a good tape for me I mean you
have the tape I don't have the tape
[Laughter]
consistency they're Papa's story that's
a lot I saw some comments on but I see I
was wondering cuz he said I do have the
tape I've heard the tape and then later
he says I don't have the table I haven't
heard the tape I wonder if there was
some legal I think so yeah he was like
oh I can't say that yeah I think I have
to assume that that's what it is yeah
he's like oh wait no I haven't heard
anything about the tape anyway great
stuff so we are moving on from Papa no
no it was a great time it was a great
moment we all have it will cherish it
forever and we got this beautiful intro
thank you Dan let me get my thoughts
together here yeah [ __ ] you Dan so let's
move on now Ella I've got I've been
surfing Instagram and first it was the
food people have captured my heart the
beauty people on Instagram have now
captured my curiosity I mean this is one
of the weirdest videos I've ever seen in
my life
look at the amount of attention that
goes to an eyelash and ultimately for
what oh yeah you got this music thank
you for I don't understand the benefit
of this like okay so this is before
after that's the after oh I don't know
that's big
I don't know because it never it doesn't
look any different but look how much
effort goes into so they put like a
guard below his eye and on his eyelid
like silicon and now they're brushing
glue on silicon and brushing the
eyelashes up onto the glue more brushing
like it's all gonna just come out so now
she's brushing she's putting some kind
of like looks like bleach on his
eyelashes this is just eyelashes this is
just eye lashes remember now she's
brushing it doesn't have a lot of
eyelashes too so if he's like right no
matter what you do it you won't really
see much if I cancel it again I cannot
tell the difference between the
beginning and the end but the amount of
grooming that goes into these eyelashes
I mean it just keeps going I know I like
it just glue and substance and now
they're dying it Wow already black was
dying it black no mascara
right now she's wiping off the dye I
mean it makes me feel he's got to be
getting that in it's uncomfortable
yeah it'll have that yes it's very I was
just in shock watching this for the
first time I just feel like all of these
eyelashes are gonna fall out at the end
after all this well I don't know what
kinda she's scraping all this black [ __ ]
off the hits shampoo I think she's
shampooing out wash it out and the
conditioner they condition is eyelashes
yeah you see those are stuck on the
right so I thought that you had this in
here and I watched it and I agree this
this video is insane so I just I don't
know I have the clip of the girl who's
like ironing her hair and then now she's
the big reveal after this like 30 layers
step and I mean
so he it's a guy who by the way I
thought it was a girl at first so get a
look I mean it looks it looks it looks
exactly the same
Rabi they're all that clumped yeah I
can't see any difference they should
have got someone with more I can't see
anything anyway that is mind-blowing
I've never been that taking grooming to
that level there like we did the hair we
did the eyebrows we did the pubes the
ass hair what's left my lashes it's the
final frontier baby push it all the way
there you have it from boys do it to
which I'm assuming is a gay beauty vlog
it's for gay men to learn Beauty chips
you know why do you say like no this
says boys do it too
what are you inferring from that could
be straight boys that wear makeup yeah
do their eyelashes you think a straight
guy would do that to his eyelashes and
you've just kidding me no if you're
straight and you do that you're gay now
I'm telling you there's not a no
straight no matter how feminine we'll go
through that I'm just I'm being honest
tell me you disagree and I'll call you a
lot just cuz you're burnt to do it
that's what I was thinking is that we
should actually can you imagine how out
of groomed my whole everything is and
then I'm just so focused on my eyelashes
like that much effort I mean sure I'll
do it but it doesn't make me gay because
I'm doing it for the show you just you
just said
Wow that's what happens when you're gay
we're gonna you get yukata help Wow
anything else you want to add take a
pill and an amount at the same time is
yesterday
No
Thank You Allah you have the Reaver I
need to turn I know we're good I feel
like that video was in that game you
know I think there could be gay alright
see these are but fun buttons they are
you guys want to review my bit my double
bit
go ahead damn what do you think apology
but I think was a little long they
dragged to use less iterations you sound
like a youtube comment what less it only
there like three times well you did the
sucking dick and then it was two dicks
and then I was three Dixon but no that's
not true
I said sucking dick getting [ __ ] in
the ass [ __ ] those are all three
different sex acts there was a there was
a dick in the mouth and the ass at the
same time yeah that's a different sex
act right that was the two and then you
said the [ __ ] thing and then you said
three as well yeah I'm just saying in
the Atlas iteration three ends are ass
right I get it I get it okay how about
this how about this that's the first one
I agree with about here let me think of
another game one that is really good
about the that's the case of dancing
yeah we thought we peaked there
there's another one you know there's
there was more beauty ones put that out
to me was was the best but I'll keep my
eyes out but this is the kind of content
that I go on Instagram for this guy
setting a he's just cruising on bouncing
on like medicine balls weights he seemed
passed by he's not touching the ground
he's like bouncing from one medicine
ball rolling from one but medicine ball
to the other there's like big deal or I
thought he was gonna fall in his face at
some point look like maybe right at the
end there that guy has practiced a lot
that's probably really hard to do I
think so yeah so there you have it it's
got a whole groupie of fans who probably
put this together for him your trainer
got you doing that either no riding the
balls just slamming into my face okay
I'm trying to think of something that's
gayer than going salsa dancing with the
platonic friends huh but I can't think
of anything there's nothing that might
be peak oh you want to review memes you
want to talk about the Sonic the
Hedgehog guess let's do it all memes
America China coronavirus this is what
we wash of the town hall the Costanza
vapenation the mandalorian no it's
prevalence Hypertime 2077 that game
that's coming out but how am I supposed
to know that because it says 2077 on it
okay it was blah I was actually boy the
microphone decide nation cringe Buster's
just a Photoshop Oh somebody's phone
cases what that was but well oh wow
pretty elaborate quite some kisses you
the way Joe Biden kisses his
granddaughter man huh what do you make
of that either a little weird you can't
kiss your granddaughter on the lips from
here I mean that's gotta stop it's gotta
stop that hurt oh this this I've lost I
love up where
you stores forget in it you know that's
real come on even if you like Trump you
got to admit that [ __ ] so good this I
don't think this is a Photoshop you want
on Twitter so there's a Photoshop your
boy Trump has got a [ __ ] no there's a
million photos of him like that
no but he's literally--he's he tweeted
this photo and said fake fake media is
is a photoshopping my face
that's definitely not a Photoshop is
that makeup or spray tan I mean this
photo is incredible it's got to be
makeup because that how can you achieve
that the only photo like that is why I
know it's not photoshopped bro this is
amateur hour you got a complete I guess
he is hair you should cover exactly
oh it's makeup it's definitely makeup I
wonder what it looks like without makeup
probably not good pale well old to just
right that's your boy right there the
main thing did I saw a picture of him
today he's [ __ ] enormous he is like
we're fat he's like a beast I think he's
morbidly obese I saw him in like a
really long suit today I wish I could
had the picture he's like a house man
Trump Trump is is fat and see what kind
of images we got here yeah you got a
problem he's that he's a size my house
dude and don't think so no okay oh wait
I just saw the photo I just was talking
about here wait no this is the one with
the face I am over it when I talk get
out get off it Ethan slimmin interesting
Jay station arrested for assault after
faking girlfriend's death ladies and
generally got him okay whatever
coronavirus outfit whatever this I don't
know why this is here I've seen it a
million times over that Papa John last
supper
whatever-whatever tell you not look at
these before you come on the show I did
but what do you want me to do they're
not that good I mean let's just stop
doing this then you're always like you
suck you suck you suck
well well sometimes they're good but
sometimes they suck is that not part of
the joy Last Supper I mean it's okay
it's not that good you know this one I
don't even know why it's here watching
Papa go pound for pound with Ethan
confirms he can eat 40 pieces in 30 days
by the way he didn't go pound for pound
he was taken by putting it down I
definitely outclassed him it's not even
let's be honest 10-point pizza Papa give
me the rise Papa derives this I did like
this one thanks Dan Bobby Lee [ __ ] you
Dan Trisha Paytas and Dan let me get my
thoughts together let me get my thoughts
together here yeah Zak on the soundboard
I finally have them all and this guy's
Costanza should we stop doing the memes
I mean I don't know I could be down to
stop doing the memes Philly do you
embrace the me we were recently talking
about how I'm the fourth most clickbait
youtuber affiliate e of all time
and he recently clicked baited me really
good he said why people are freaking out
about h2 h3 and he briefly mentioned me
talking about what was it Bloomberg or
something I don't know or Sanders that I
endorsed Bernie Sanders I was a and he
goes he showed a picture mean he said
thanks for the thumbnail bro so there
you have it and I said I said Phil thank
you for keeping me I need to stay in
that top five because my ego will be
even get into the top five and you stay
in the top five we get into the stay up
number four get in to the dish
you know I'm number four I don't know
why you got to try to take that for me
have you even if you want to take it
from me so desk really bad why don't you
get the true count right here you were
in the top five for youtubers she
checked the top count if you want to
take this from me until you can
empirically prove then that these are
other people like Lawrence okay
I will I will what's her name Laurent
what's her name Jeff Jennifer Lawrence
does not have more because that's what
the person who did the crunching excited
there's no way Jennifer Lawrence has
been more click baited than me it
doesn't make sense so unless you want to
get in the trenches and do the work said
she's a giant celebrity but how often is
she in headlines
she was in the news a bunch because she
was involved with the the fappening
thing I didn't look at those that would
be really that would be really really
inconsiderate to look at happening no
there's no way that she's can more
thumbnails mean if you want to say that
I didn't get it okay
until then Dan you better [ __ ] give
it up because I'm number I get you can I
get you on tape like Papa right now
saying that this you're saying top five
of everybody your youtubers of everybody
everybody of all time okay we'll see
what happens
of all time you want talk [ __ ] you
better back it up sunk the Hedgehog
reviews are out we've been telling our
scores when we front when we watch the
original trailer we're like oh man this
is gonna be like so there's anyone worst
movies of all time and we originally
guessed on rotten tomato this I guess 12
L I guess 20 and guessed 14 dangus zero
balls II guess and Zack 35 well since
they redid the sonic and re-released a
trailer we reissued guesses I guess 50
ela kept her guess at 20 in 36 dan went
from 0 to 40 that's a quite an
about-face quite a flip-flop and Zack
went from 35 to 55 well
the sonic movie is out and we have the
results so do I have a drumroll still
Dan are you going to see sonic tonight
uh-huh Ian's gonna see it Zack said he
was gonna soar known samples excellent
doing Hank that's in quarantine
yeah mm-hmm the results are are you
ready to uh yeah are you ready as I
predicted they did go down from what it
was last night everybody there it is
63% so in the end not that interesting
you know I guess 50 I feel like I
should've won because that guest last
and he gets 55 that's like guessing
$1.00 in prices right but Zack wins but
he's not here so [ __ ] no reason I win
but the audience score is 94% what yeah
I mean I think it's just a mean midnight
showing dude you know people around the
block I got tell you I bought my tickets
in advance like a last week and when I
went to go buy it there was literally no
seats sold in the theater I was the
first person to buy and it was like it's
like a 7:00 p.m. showing tonight Wow oh
well that was a week ago
actually you know what I'm gonna do
let's see how many seats are at like a a
p.m. show right now yeah
Sonic the Hedgehog this is going to be
interesting let's see let's look at the
ArcLight that's kind of funny because I
don't think anyone will see it at the
ArcLight that's what I'm saying 8:15
8:15 Friday night it's time to see go to
the movies right yep so let's say two
adults big debut Jim Carrey you know
you've got to see this it's totally
available the blue is available to play
stakeout that is like fully available
yeah that's the 8 o'clock show sonic is
not good there not even a Jim Carrey I'm
gonna cover it cover his acting costs
let's check the let's check your show
Arclight
seven that's what all people are gonna
know oh no this this hat will happen
after you've already been there right
yeah like I want someone to go murder my
producer I need him yeah I mean looking
a little bit more full but still not
that impressed I mean this is opening
night yeah I guess I mean the ArcLight
though you wanna check it yeah I mean
like maybe the AMC is sold out you know
let's see let's be fair let's check a
different theater Regency Van Nuys plant
let's check seven people like seven
apparently this interesting I think so I
know you're coming from but I do think
so Fandango you [ __ ] they're
making me like enter my credit or even
get to select the seed really so Ian is
a hyped for this movie let that on the
show but he's a sonic boy at heart
Ian's a fan of everything man just like
Zach those two guys love everything it's
like ian loves Kanye in loves ariana
grande apparently he loved me enough to
reach out you know love Sam in burrito
Taylor Swift Taylor's Ian loved me and
you enough to reach out cold and beg for
a job what I've always wondered is if he
still has that reverence and love and I
can always try to get it from him but he
never quite answers used to be found
I wonder if he wouldn't work for Kanye
Fourier you must he would probably hate
his guts so I think I'm doing all right
woody hate Kanye yes yep
that seems hard to believe
I just wish that he would look at me
with the same reverence like what do I
have to do to win his heart back Jim
Carrey did an interview that he's
getting called me to Don now here let's
judge for ourselves
he was trending people are trying to
cancel Jim Perry for this comment in
this interview you tell me what you
think about this Ilan I already have my
opinion what's your opinion that's
[ __ ] you have a prejudice situation
oh okay well sure is there anything
still left on your bucket list just you
it's all done now [ __ ] list moment in
your life when you look back something
you always want what a dumb question
sorry yes sir it's not I you know I'm
not gonna judge it these circuit
interviews are done nightmare right I've
been invited to do this [ __ ] and I was
like never it's so awkward you're just
one of a million you're trying to like
be unique and stand out and you take a
photo and you're like why would you
carry it's like you're just like another
face that they have to also you're
forced to sit in front yeah it's just a
chore for him it's not oh yeah he does
dude he's there to see you know exactly
they also always liquor everybody up for
these so like to like loosen them up or
whatever so chances although Jim Carrey
is like I hope you have to be a drink of
this these are the professionals you'd
have to be a real dum-dum to actually go
there and get drunk
well also it's like they're they're
extremely wealthy it's like open bar
look oh I better drink it's free booze I
think it's bad just make it tolerable
cuz it's a miserable thing you just sit
there and do interviews over and over
again for 10 hours yeah the same things
drunk but I refuse to go there and be
like I'm so special
with Jim Carrey it's not like that he
hates you you understand he hates you
and he will not remember you anyway Wow
there's so many things
honest to god they just keep so anyway
did you people were saying that that was
a me-too moment I feel like he goes on
to give us every line so now so it kind
of was just like making a joke so I
didn't really have a problem with this
one you know I heard an alternate
explanation that he was saying to be
interviewed by you that's how I
perceived it yeah but even how it's done
it was a failures it was just like a
joke right like well obviously he was
joking no I mean like even if it's in
what you just said kind of explains what
he was thinking as a joke but even if he
meant I want to be with you I don't
think you yeah I don't think you
wouldn't say it like that if that's what
he meant even if he did mean that I
still not offended I think that it takes
like a few instances or something
because we keep going we've seen spindle
rows at VIN diesel oh yeah I think Ben
Affleck like sexually assaulted someone
during one of these things those awesome
sort of like grabbing her tits or
something cameraman or what's that the
Red Hot Chili Peppers there have been so
many great ones we've seen somewhere
it's clear that it's not cool when I
watch this I was like clearly it just
made a joke some fun come on I mean come
on are you kidding
why are we even discussing this I mean
the way that he phrased it it's pretty
clear the joke yeah like the bucket list
was that being interviewed by you not
sleeping with her but even if it was
sleeping with her I mean I'm still not
offended
he's just goofing around yeah he didn't
proceed I think the main point is that
you can see that he's just goofing
around and then he goes on to like
whatever back to the answer you know
it's not like he keeps actually being
creepy about it
yeah like Vin Diesel was like oh my god
you're the most beautiful girl in the
world I mean I feel like I'm in
beautiful world didn't say yeah okay
look I just have a beautiful world would
you just send me then other Vin Diesel
one you want to go back for a little for
a little I'm in let's watch it again
[ __ ] it this one did his boys make the
sauce well yeah this is where did this
outfit is so off the chain do you have
any comments on this outfit it's up
there with Ben Affleck statu lad I think
that is the worst outfit ever
plaid v-neck super high cutoff like oh
my god there's no sleep at all with
aviators shirt for a guy is just on four
gave a ball unless it's a tank top and
they're athletic or that's it different
fine yeah but the only thing would make
this shirt worse if there was a hoodie
on it it's it's already at that level of
bed for me because it's got buttons and
it's like plaid the Aviator aviator
glasses it's like a serious shirt but
also because he has no hair there's so
much flesh it feels like he's naked
there's just so much flesh there it is
so much skin what about his voice did
listen there
look at this woman she's so beautiful
he's don't tell me they got him down
let's go let's see yeah that's
unappropriate my god definitely not your
PR person
he's not gonna spear a person you cut if
you look off this green don't know I
love his voice man and he thinks that
guys just think she's not beautiful so
he keeps arguing when I was like look at
her yeah she's like no no no no she's
fine yeah she's not beautiful when you
get that drunk you think you're being
charming and they're laughing cuz it's
awkward but you you're drunk so you like
get a little like you get like a drunk
lobotomy you just you're like but you
know you're some you know it wasn't
drunk when you put on the outfit well it
was it but we don't know that but it was
in his it was in his suitcase or
wherever you know he bought it sober
presumably we got a sound byte something
from that I love this interview
[Music]
do you think she's flattered over it
she's over it you don't think she wants
to do her job she's trying to ask good
questions like tell me you're not even
taking her seriously
yes not good content but do you think
that she she might go with him yeah but
still let's get the interview at least
guys really
guys there's a joke how am I supposed to
sit up here when I'm just looking at
such beauty he's pretty but it's not
like it's not like you know what I mean
it's not like his type or something he's
just drunk she's like she's like she's
like you know attractive and he's drunk
and he's like how's this guy movie star
he's like a insel I'm getting in selvage
from Vin Diesel it sounds like somebody
pitch shift his voice in his throat goes
off he doesn't have to like when he's
going down on girls he probably doesn't
have to like do you know cunnilingus he
just goes and the vibrations are so deep
and like it's so vibrating I probably
just gets them off just his voice spread
and right in there you just he doesn't
have to do anything he just goes you're
so beautiful and it's like so bassy you
know when you like turn the bass up and
[ __ ] like vibrates like crazy that's
probably how he gets one at all
[Laughter]
beautiful world it's got to be the worst
line he thinks he's so charming right
now - it's the worst boy that turns me
on our Vin Diesel was 52 he's still
doing too fast too furious hell yeah
baby that's all she got I think someone
was like our time is up because she was
like she nodded because you only get two
minutes with them she's like thought
about this she's planned she's prepared
should she may have even flown in from
Brazil for this interview and then what
sits down in front of her drunk Vin
Diesel she had this for two minutes so
tell me about yourself she's gonna take
that back to Brazil never work again so
what do you get we sent you out to LA
that was a huge expense for us you know
here's what I got and I thought that my
throat for a week doing that all right
Bloomberg here we go let's get into the
Bloomberg hole we've talked about [ __ ]
Jerry here we've talked about [ __ ] Jerry
on our on our Channel
they're behind this I knew it from the
minute I saw this because he posted on
[ __ ] Jerry
but he also posts on all the top meme
accounts sir
let me show you what went down let me
show you the one I [ __ ] Jerry
specifically here why can't their name
be [ __ ] Jerry and I can't even say their
name without my video being [ __ ]
Jarrod yeah actually I probably get
yellowed on this highlight because you
just said [ __ ] but why is why can
their Navy [ __ ] Jerry
well Instagram what am I doing wrong you
should turn this into Instagram TV the
one thing I have thought about though
with what I don't know I don't want to
do it and I'm far from it but like what
can you do a subscription-based thing
where it's behind a paywall I mean
that's so lame it feels so lame I don't
know it's not anything I'm really
seriously considering but it's just like
at a certain point you want to make a
high-quality show you can't do it here
that's why our show sucks oh my fault he
goes hello Jerry my granddaughter showed
me this account your memes are very
humorous can you post a meme that lets
everyone know I'm the cool candidate
what did you have in mind when you're
the cool candidate goof that will cost
like a billion dollars
what's your venmo and then they says he
does look pretty cool and yes this
really is sponsored by Mike Bloomberg I
can do that it was real until I saw that
they said then it's real well then you
realize yeah
so what do you think happened he has
like a media kind of like the laundry
company
maybe he's hired everybody in the
industry yeah so then they're like
except me we should approach meme pages
everybody in that media I mean it's
insane the amount it's almost like
Sheamus it's like 300 million dollars in
a quarter everybody media is now work
just working for him
I wonder what ungodly amount of money he
got for this too it's like Oh Mike
Bloomberg yeah the
the price why has it Mike approached me
I want some of that Bloomberg money you
know what I'm saying where is your main
page this is way better than me page
would you do a sponsor for Mike
Bloomberg I don't know half a million
bucks
Bloomberg money he's like here's a half
a million dollars
here's what I would do I would say yes
Mike Bloomberg I'll take your money I'll
do all say I'll say your name say I've
been paid to say that Mike Bloomberg is
this I've been paid to say Mike
Bloomberg is that mm-hmm these are not
my I'm not endorsing Mike Bloomberg I've
simply been paid to tell you exist what
they did here yeah but I feel like this
is uh they're saying he's cool bother
saying it does look pretty yeah but
they're they're meta it's like a meta
endorsement it's like that they knew
that not but they're not really like
endorsing and it's a cosign it is kind
of a cosign
so what you described the you with it
would also be a cosigner yeah it would
be it would be ultimately so you just
hold out virtually yes for half a
million bucks I'd yeah you wouldn't do
it for half a million bucks what would
be hanging things out and burn I'm
feeling the Bern
yeah I'm feeling I'm firing the bent the
Bern of $500,000 it should be in my
pocket that's not it's burning a hole
right there anyway pretty shocking stuff
here yeah but you know I'm just it's
like what am i what am i clearly he had
nothing to do with this he's an old guy
he doesn't understand Instagram he has
nothing to do so what is it that
granddaughter story made up yes
well each one you see you got here's one
on whatever trashcan Paul I don't know
what all this [ __ ] is a lot of them are
owned by [ __ ] Jerry
hello Paul congratulations on your
followers I actually have my own meme
page just starting out don't judge
trying to get my numbers up would you be
interested in joining a like-for-like
group with me and some other candidates
okay boomer and yes this really is
sponsored see but they're all being kind
of like fine because you have sponsored
they're not you have to be meta
otherwise it would be a disaster but you
have to understand that I just can't
believe that we've come to this I guess
that's what's really shocking but [ __ ] I
mean [ __ ] Jerry's like presidential
candidates sponsoring means he's
reaching people where they are that's
what they said he's not wrong
but [ __ ] the fact that [ __ ] Jerry is
doing their media is just makes me sick
that these guys are still doing there's
just these guys are just unscrupulous
they suck they just suck it's the fire
festival yeah they did the fire festival
they've been stealing memes before that
I mean they're just they suck like
imagine being the Bloomberg deciding
yeah I well the fire festival guys they
produced the document they they produced
the documentary the documentary on the
fire festival and then when it turned
out to be a scam which they knew it was
they sold it to Netflix and produced a
exposing fire festival well they did
more than just the documentary they were
doing the marketing right right right
now and they were enrolled it's like
somehow they twisted that to her
advantage and and ended up I don't know
man was associated that they made that
documentary mm-hmm no I could no no we
didn't know anything they minimize their
involvement cuz because they were
deleting comments on on Instagram yeah
[ __ ] anyway Mike Bloomberg I was on
the fence I'm gonna be honest I was on
the fence about Mike because I'm like he
does have experience
yeah yeah but I'm out Mike's out for me
after this show any association with
[ __ ] Jerry's a dead in the water anyway
I've endorsed Bernie Sanders officially
yeah come on I am endorsing Bernie
Sanders for
president its de Larry David of version
over president we must get the 1% Mike
Bloomberg is in the top 1% of 1%
we must get 50% of that 1% and give it
to the bottom 99% and then 32% of all
young people on student debt we're gonna
take that 23% and turn it into 0% and
then 50% of the nation will be rise out
of poverty and the top 1% will be forced
to pay for the health care I endorsed
Bernie Sanders for president I do I
donated a thousand dollars and announced
it on Twitter whose big news it was that
Wow ethan klein you made it into philip
defranco video right that's big news
today you had her in the thumbnail I was
in the thumbnail baby his title was
people are freaking out but it's like
wow that's nobody's freaking out mm-hmm
I'm always surprised by his thought his
titles like nobody's freaking out you
used that so much it's like come on it's
not that doesn't work you can't keep
saying people are freaking out I don't
think you can really criticize titles
anymore yeah
after the approach that we've taken
jacksFilms announced study is having a
baby yeah I mean I I see what you mean I
mean obviously it's like a little cheeky
I hope that comes across to people that
titles like we're trying to be funny
I mean it's just I mean obvious whole
thing of saying like on ironically
people are freaking out like what are
people actually freaking out like one
can you warrant saying that people freak
out over shed all the time there's just
people whose people I think Brando is on
doing I think of freaking out I mean
that's that's so extreme that's like
what people do when there's like a
shooting like I'm freaking out like
you're running and screaming that's
freaking out
right okay like nobody-nobody freaked
out about me endorsing Bernie Sanders
and he does freakin and all caps who
when do people ever freak in all caps
out Pearl Harbor 9/11 but people don't
freak out in all caps they may freak out
about your gay jokes today I doubt it
we'll see those those Billy Dee I know
exactly let's say I'm working on the
inside those numbers a wildly irrational
reaction or spell of behavior as the
dictionary does wildly irrational wildly
irrational so just the fact that it's
wildly that does extreme behavior like
freaking out is like punching a hole in
the wall it's not just being like oh but
I doubt people even did that anyway what
do you think about Mike Bloomberg and
buying out media on main pages Dan it we
live in hell it's awful I mean [ __ ] all
these mean pages anyways it's Smallville
content we've for reasons we've
litigated on the show in the past but
yeah I mean you know it's just this is
this this is just dystopia like it's
just it makes me feel so bad so many
people are following these pages of [ __ ]
so soup like all the famous people
follow all this stuff yeah one of the
here's here's all the meemers involved
it's called meme 2020 they started a new
company so stupid right which we found
out yeah meme 2020 is most of the
executives from Jerry media apparently
the main dude the Elliot whatever his
name is is is technically not part of
this yeah whatever
yeah I'm sure yeah well cares there's
all these guys are in on it together
all right don't you feel like you're
being pander to it though like these
guys are not funny if you watch them in
a documentary they're not funny at all
like don't you just feel so pander to
meme 2020 it's like when you are you
can't monetize memes otherwise it's just
not funny anymore meme 2020 these guys
trying to be businessmen anyway one of
them that they used was white people
humor so Mike Bloomberg bought a media
Buy on white people humor so
congratulations to him and do you even
lift so there you have it
congratulations Mike Bloomberg he's
gonna spend like a billion dollars and
not for like nothing yeah it's crazy
crazy and all these people it's just so
much money to be made so there you have
it Mike Bloomberg said here's their
statement on the matter you can tell me
what you think about this Hildago Mike
Bloomberg 20/20 has teamed up with
social creators to collaborate with the
campaign including the meme world
sabrina sink a senior national spokesman
for the bloomberg campaign said in a
statement while a meme strategy may be
new to presidential politics we're
betting it will be an effective
component to reach people where they are
and compete with president Trump's
powerful digital operation see it's so
it's so cynical it's because some focus
group they they realized that in 2016
Trump like won the meme war so to speak
like his supporters like all the 4chan
people and everything like had that kind
of organic internet support happening
for him and just like everything in life
he thinks he
just by that and what does he do he goes
and hires the [ __ ] fire fest guys
just like the most incompetent
lowest-common-denominator [ __ ] meemers
out there to be like to just kind of
like artificially give him what he
perceives Trump to have it's like it's
not gonna [ __ ] work it's just gonna
make people think that you're loser like
well and I've already seen like the
backlash to it is bad like all of the
other like all the meme pages on
Instagram that aren't a part of this are
just dogging on all these pages now so I
mean I who is this even for like who's
gonna support Bloomberg well I think
you're actually wrong because the
initial posts like on [ __ ] Jerry I saw
everybody thought at first before people
started making fun of it I saw everyone
thought it was hilarious
and a lot of people in my friend Network
were liking it commenting and doing
laughing emojis your friend like I saw
people were like oh that your friends
liked it do you think that they thought
it was fake though no I think they
thought it was real and that it was
funny but the big difference between the
Trump is that it was a grassroots meme
camp exactly and so and it's so awesome
trumpet-like that [ __ ] was that [ __ ] was
funny like because it also Trump is just
on Twitter all day and he's good at it
right and hit the shitty tweets just saw
outrageous it is so funny it's just so
ridiculous
but Mike Bloomberg I know had no
involvement doesn't understand social
media right now and and and he's not
this isn't something he cares about
while Trump is on social media he's a he
actually memes hard yeah and and it's a
grassroots campaign so it's the
difference but but that being said it
does it did seem to work because before
like go go to one the hero let me let me
just pull the [ __ ] Jerry and like give
him for example they were Anders their
back that was the other aspect we didn't
mention is that all most of these pages
are private normally but I think as part
of this they were paid to become public
to get as many eyes on it as possible
follow them to see I think they went
private like that only after world about
class yeah yeah I wasn't always like
that it wasn't always like so so the
post has four hundred and fourteen
thousand likes it's a lot and like
clapping and like smiling laughing
emojis Wow
the choice is clear oh boy tomboy or
pink a - not like this
you know what they're doing they're
flooding the top with their own meme
pages clearing out the criticism right
because they can remove that they always
take on big accounts well we know that
they've remove comments before yeah but
just for example let me look at how is
normal posts do actually the only post
videos now for some reason because oh I
see yeah so here's a normal post from
the next day afterward and it has 360
thousand likes do you know what's so
embarrassing it's just a stolen tweet
from this person they barely keep the
name it just so that they can say they
get it yeah they like cut her face out
and barely left the Twitter name in and
cut it off kind of Katy Perry comments
on it goals that's what I mean that is
so weird to me it's not even theirs it's
not even their content goals Katy Perry
said I mean what is wrong with you why
would you would all crushing what the
[ __ ] you know here's a picture from a
week earlier it has two hundred and
thirty thousand views
I mean likes so yeah so that one was
alright really high performing crazy
these guys are really like bottom tier
[ __ ] tier
you know all the hoops we have to jump
through here and these guys just push
sort of the [ __ ] they want there's no
rules even as [ __ ] in his name like all
the [ __ ] I have to go through fate it's
Facebook I mean man they I mean Facebook
is the enemy of the people as far as I'm
concerned what their moderation is just
not not moderation they don't care I
mean they like so what's with all these
brands on YouTube like oh well we gotta
take the brands meanwhile on Facebook
they're CPMs are insane
and they don't give a [ __ ] about
anything that's on their platform I mean
they theoretically do remove stuff
theoretically but yeah it doesn't seem
like it's a lot oh we have to protect
our brands meanwhile Facebook's like
livestream of a live shoot us live
streaming a person going on a mosque and
murdering people yeah like no one cares
like yeah keep the ads going keep the
ads going public John said the n-word
we're gonna remove your video from
trending oh he didn't woops live
streaming of school shooting Oh keypads
well I'm sure that did get taken down I
would hope that got taken in yeah but I
had the platforms fine you happen that
happens on YouTube the platform gets
taken down everybody dies Facebook huh
[Music]
there was a Facebook feed were they
kidnapped some dudes kidnapped a trump
supporter who's like low IQ and they
held him as a hostage and beat the [ __ ]
out of him and tortured him on Facebook
live oh yeah that's fine the platforms
fine there's no problem there let's keep
the ads running this is why we needed
yang cuz I feel like someone like him
might actually enforce something well
I'm hoping that Bernie will have a
cabinet position for yang I'm the
technology sector I'll be doped oh we
got to keep up we got to keep a low IQ
individual captive
torture them live what's your CPM bro
should we say that yang dropped out in
case that anyone Oh yang dropped out sad
day and was pretty sad yeah you didn't
just he had his moment but people just I
don't know for some reason I mean he was
on the stage he had a really good
performance and I don't know he just he
had his moment but I think people never
took him seriously yeah I hear a lot of
people say maybe next time he fear ons
again yeah I mean he cut it he came out
of nowhere
ya know he had a much bigger mountain to
climb than a lot of the other candidates
that are you know public and well-known
and vetted and everything I mean he
literally came out of nowhere and did
really well for himself considering that
I mean polling above I mean he outlasted
US senators in like beta Rourke and
Camilla Harris and like all yea major
political figures I mean it's it bado
about is it is it named beta or or beta
O'Rourke that was funny
I agree and there's a world of
opportunity now for Angie Inc so so he's
gonna be good he's gonna be just fine
this quarter he's spent this quarter
alone he spent two hundred million
dollars in total he spent three hundred
and ten million on ad buys you talking
about Bloomberg ya know what everyone
else included including Trump was 115
that's what blows my mind is that when
you you're even including the other side
and he's still outpaces by so much he
has accepted no donations he is the
ninth richest person in the world well
[ __ ] me to that level of wealth is just
ungodly he's right behind the suck
actually fifty four seventy seven can we
get all these old Fox out of here god
I'm a young guy to be President man it
would be nice
Jeff Bezos is far and away number one
the younger guys are like someone like
zotkin Bezos they're thinking to
themselves we already around the country
we don't need your presence just
liability yeah yeah the gloom Brooks
just bored
he's like I'm retired I got nothing
better let's look at this Jeff Bezos
number one with 131 billion it's pretty
divorce or this is from 2009 2000 1990
my that net worth might be pre divorced
okay so I think that's probably still
all being litigated I mean it probably
will be yeah that's gonna be a long
process I think he's gonna be right back
on the top even if he can be okay even
if he loses 30 billion and the divorce
he's still number one even if he loses
how much 30 billion he's still 30 cuz I
remember hearing that she got thirty
billion dollars yes see these rankings
are from 2019 but I think they're from
earlier in the year I just pulled up a
thing because I thought I remembered and
yeah sure enough I think because of the
divorce and everything Bill Gates has
top Bezos Bill Gates is now the richest
person in the world again not for long
yeah loser
Bill Gates has a cool ninety six point
five billion Warren Buffett eighty two
point five billion Bernard Amal I don't
know who that loser is always French
well I think that's the guy who owns
Louie Vuitton yeah fashion isn't that
crazy
Jesus that's the case for they all it's
Spanish guy on there too is they don't
just own louis vuitton by the way this
company owns like every love your brand
reducer pretty shocking corporate LLC
subset some cities this is gonna blow
your mind
Fendi Marc Jacobs Louie Vuitton Kenzo
Vinci Fenty they are fancy and finding
yeah fancy or
those are all huge brands Tiffany and Co
they own huh
Bulgari do their portfolios crazy they
own Hennessy alcohol uh-huh
they I mean there's like there's like
actually like 50 companies here
Christian Dior and Melia Pucci there
everything is all really big friends in
Mexico
Carlos sim coming out of course 64
billion was this [ __ ] do Mexican
business tycoon investor philanthropist
I love other a philanthropist is like
yeah I would be too if I had 60 billion
you know what I mean oh he's a
philanthropist yeah [ __ ] off you [ __ ]
all over the earth I make 60 billion you
know you really have to be to make 60
billion dollars just by the very nature
of it like the shittiest billionaire
Jeff Bezos is by far the shitty spinner
I don't anything about this guy and you
know I bet we've had discussions about
good Bill Gates I like Bill Gates he's
donating all of his wealth when he dies
Jeff Bezos is a [ __ ] sleazeball at
least give your employees like a proper
bathroom break you know it just sounds
like you're worth 131 billion just
spread just take ten of that and spread
it out let your employees a little more
your margins can be a little tighter you
can afford it dude he just bought the
most expensive house in Los Angeles it's
like all over the news 165 million
dollars for him and his girlfriend it's
so lavish it's like broking him not flex
just buy the second most expensive I
think it's more I think it was the
biggest residential real estate purchase
ever in the country engine 65 and by the
way do uh do crunch this what is a
hundred sixty five million dollars as a
percentage of 131 billion if you would
thirty-five million hundred sixty-five
million that's what the house cost what
percentage is that of 131 billion some
big numbers yes big numbers don't forget
a digit how many billions is he have 131
billion she jesus [ __ ] christ uh god
I mean it's the 0.12%
it looks like at 0.1% seems high so it's
like a tenth of one percent yeah right
you think that sounds high of you so you
have a hundred so you said you says it's
point one percent so 0.1% of a hundred
thousand dollars to put it in context if
you have a hundred thousand dollars
that's like spending a hundred dollars
he bought the most expensive house ever
sold in this country at least there's
place of castles in Europe or some [ __ ]
so four hundred dollars of a hundred
thousand goddamn that's disgusting Jeff
Bezos is and meanwhile it's like
nice bit that's all right I like it and
I get like I don't like it
Bloomberg Ganga's out endorsed Bernie
Sanders Amber Rose got a tattoo on her
face that may rival Ben Affleck you look
tell me what you think
check it out it says does not it doesn't
it's a [ __ ] huge tattoo under for
this is bat it says bash / I don't like
it go ahead and explain that why that's
not worse I don't like it I don't like
it
she says she's been making comments
about she says beauty is not what's on
the outside
it's what's on the inside that counts
inside my [ __ ] and inside my heart she
said that's funny words wisdom she says
she goes on for the people that are
telling me I'm too pretty for a face tat
I didn't say that are you think she's
not pretty well she's a little beat
she's seen better days
what's pretty it's got so much plastic
surgery yeah I mean know that I mean
well that's like a highly uh that's a
highly photoshopped image of her like
here let me show you what's up what's
really going on with her Daily Mail oh
my god she's dating the Joker I mean
she's kind of a mess I'm being honest
yours yeah it went well I'm not really
okay maybe I'm being too harsh I mean it
looks to me like she's wearing a I think
she looks insane and she's wearing like
a leopard skin trash bag she looks like
she looks like when you pull the me
undies all the way up to your chest
right by the way I always wondered as
the arms attached to the body as a
separate attached house attention what
do you make of this outfit
I think Ethan gotta tell you I gotta
break it to you go ahead gotta break
you're heavy here talked invite wrong
amber yeah I didn't call her fat I'm
just saying that you know sometimes
people get all this plastic surgery and
it makes it and they don't age
gracefully she's a pretty girl okay
would you [ __ ] her I'm not into girls no
let's go ahead yo you making a point I'm
just saying you know sometimes he just
got out 36 just same age as me two years
older what what say it che say literally
what you trying to say just just gotta
look at yourself and that's it well I
didn't call her fat and by the way Trump
she's not fat in color fat Trump has
made fun of people for being fat he
calls people fat all the time and I do
think it's slightly ironic and funny
that he is a big fatso and that is true
that being said I mean yeah I'm fat I
acknowledge that too I'm a monster what
what do you want me to say what do you
want me to say but but I the fact that
Trump is actually a like enormous is
funny because he makes fun of the fact
he makes fun of people's appearance he's
like a bully uni tries to hide it by
wearing these ridiculous long suits but
he's huge but I feel like in her case
she's making a good effort to look good
you know it's not really like what did I
even say again I I don't remember I was
just making fun of her face that I guess
he said she's she looks beat something
yeah I said she looks beat it's my take
you could say the same thing about me
but that's my point but I guess I'm not
I'm not getting fitnah let's talk about
the face time you think I'm being do you
think I'm being sexist
No okay not sexist judgmental yeah
overly judgmental yeah she looked be I'm
just trying going over the comment her
tattoo looks ridiculous but I mean you
know without the tattoo I don't think
there's anything wrong with her she's
pretty lady okay
she's ruining it with the tattoo I agree
yeah I agree I you know I just but even
that is subjective yeah I suppose I
don't think so well then she goes on to
explain she says for people tell me that
I'm too far too pretty well don't you
think that's just a little arrogant I'm
far too pretty for a face that I don't
see people saying that okay focus he
then okay
she's way too pretty for a face that
anybody's way too pretty for a face time
that's the point we're all beautiful
snowflakes that we should nobody should
have faced as we're all too beautiful
I'm way too pretty for face that are the
same people that are telling me I'm too
pretty even if they thought I was ugly
and lie to me old no grammar letting me
low or they would just tell me I'm ugly
ha ha so either what you're gonna do the
mole the story is do whatever the [ __ ]
you want in life
move ah mwah mwah
so it says bash slash its heart kids
needs oh I didn't know that bash is
short for Sebastian and then her other
kid is just named slash
which is a little odd I mean I don't
like the tattoo but I don't like a lot
of tutors lately I do think I think it's
just a matter of taste
I don't think necessarily this one is
that bad we've seen way worse in my
opinion okay well I have another one
that you can judge Chris Brown and and
Chris Brown recently got a face tattoo
this is a trend this is a fad this face
that things that I think people are
getting we know who started it
our friends yeah definitely popularized
the base fast and in his case I've
gotten used to seeing them I mean I
guess he then started he popularized I
would say but like now you got people
like Chris Brown putting sneakers why
shoe did I hate Chris Brown I hear them
on guys
shoenice it's Jordan when I hear um well
you got a shoe on your face whenever I
hear Chris Brown on the radio I skip it
off so hard got you douche he's criminal
those lines bad worse than bash slash
yeah I just hate how it's part of his
facial hair I mean Tim this is port but
I also hate that it's just a shoe you
just like have to do with Kobe I mean
Jordan actually hurt the to had to do it
Kobe she did it after what happened to
him and his daughter she was inspired
yeah two-faced at mm-hmm I had some
other in that dock that were inspired by
Kobe but oh yeah yeah yeah you scroll
down I mean in crazy brown this case I
don't know I really don't like it it's
like literally just a shoe on your face
God Aaron Carter is such a this one's
awful think we've seen this one no just
it's like why don't we looked at it on
the show
life is a mess dude no matter what kind
of turmeric and like sophisticated
classes and slick yeah your life is
always a mess bro forever good time in
this case it also looks like it's just a
bad like drawing I don't know what is
going on there it's just a fad I hate to
say it but this whole face that thing
people are gonna be make it having a lot
of regrets and ten years from now I
think bastions slashing back mom what
the [ __ ] is wrong with you hmm
thank you for this no Dan he wrote Amber
Rose as a model and actress so thing
where that at the end of this there's a
bullet point it's just
Amber Rose is a model and actress a lot
of times we're talking about these
people I would look it up before putting
using the store okay speaking of Trump
tell me if this is peak insanity or not
just watch this press statement of Trump
by the way means and tell me if it
concerns Jennifer drugs by the way means
that's serious they're getting a maximum
penalty and you know what the maximum
penalty is in China for that and it goes
very quickly it's interesting we have
Singapore they have very little drug
problem where you have China they have
very little drug problem states with a
very powerful death penalty on drug
dealers don't have a drug problem
I don't know that our country is ready
for that but if you look throughout the
world the countries with a powerful
death penalty death penalty with a fair
but quick trial they have very little if
any drug problem that includes China
same criminal in China for drugs by the
way means that's their getting a maximum
penalty and you know what them thousand
right is that max insanity he's admiring
countries who execute drug dealers
quickly
well doesn't shock you can you do I
don't know he did so much that shocked
me already that I'm just like we love
executing drug dealers
that's a peak insanity though I sold
drugs should mean you'd be executed
right it's good point good point now
we're now we're god-fearing citizens who
pay our taxes God fare well it's just
what you say good citizens fear God and
pay taxes huh
I earn IRS ladies and gentlemen this is
calling always on scam likely that I
don't answer the IRS from India line
this is the IRS
oh you also $10,000 oh you everybody's
getting these calls yeah you call you
are going to prison
so kill you go to prison or you pay a
thousand dollars have you seen that guy
twitch streamer I think his name's like
boom yeah yeah he's awesome oh my god
it's unbelievable I wanted to get him on
the show yeah pranks them
he creates like sterile environments on
his computer and lets them hack him and
he puts like nude pics to the extent
that he's able to get into their
computer and like delete their files no
way yeah
some are just unbelievably satisfying to
watch excuse me mr. Klein hi this is mr.
Smith from the IRS [ __ ] you guy you owe
us
10,000 and it's like that people like uh
uh like old people mm-hm they're like
why and the only way to pay us is to go
[Laughter]
Starbucks gift cards you must go to
Western what is it called the like the
money Grand Place Western Union you must
go to Western know your net 12 p.m. and
pay us by Western units when nonnamous
check cashers check it's so absurd cuz
it's so crazy that it's like who would
ever fall for this but then you realize
there wouldn't be thousands of people
doing well people weren't falling for it
all the times well it's just old people
I know it's sad they got my grandma if
they go really they go someone like I
guess who got my info and knew my
grandma's name in my name they go hey
grandma this is Ethan they don't sound
anything like me saw me I'm trapped in
Mexico I got busted in Mexico and I need
you to send me three thousand dollars to
bail me out
well it's like but you know the premise
doesn't make any sense why didn't I call
my parents
well didn't call my siblings why am i
calling my grandma why am i in Mexico
and but she was ready to do it but my
brother was living with her at the time
and he intervened nice mm-hm but that's
a classic scam where they write just
preying on old people so you suck to be
that hold be so [ __ ] hold that you
can't even like make sense like [ __ ] you
you're like oh it's like I can't imagine
being in that state of mind be so
gullible it's like you really slipped
mentally if you fall for that [ __ ] I
guess I'm just so fragile everything is
like you're just kind of like in
survival sucks you know [ __ ] sucks
science you got like how am I I'm 34 I
figure out my I'll probably lose start
losing mental capacity around 80
you got like 45 years to figure this
[ __ ] out
the senses are like Ethan just exercise
I'm like [ __ ] you are you like toying
with your microphone or something yes oh
sorry I was born here well we've done it
all there's a lot of others like small
[ __ ] I see if there's anything good er
no yeah alright two hours you know
that's it we cam we've seen we've talked
we've laughed we've cried and we haven't
cried gets home about our guest next
week
PewDiePie right yes people will be
joining us now I'm just gonna tell you
guys Felix we had two podcasts in row
that we had to cancel so I'm just gonna
start saying that PewDiePie cancelled at
the top of every episode as a gag so you
guys have made it to this far know what
that gag is about and everyone else will
be confused so I'm just gonna start
saying sorry - PewDiePie we we had to
reschedule at the top of every episode
from now on because it's confusing I've
announced it so many times that let's
just make it a gag so next week is it
all back to a normal schedule to have
any guests and yeah we have PewDiePie
coming on oh well okay but for real
no no guests on the books next week okay
we just have a slew of them and we're
going back into normal mode not a couple
weeks we have all of our tree coming up
I don't know when that is should I reach
out to I was trying to get Gary Spivey
that would be really cool and we even
have a Gary Spivey costume - we right
brought so would be the best he just
stares at me the whole time if you guys
have suggestions I'm looking for
interesting X Factor a little off the
beaten
path it's gotta be someone who is like
approachable you know cuz open not
famous
we don't have agencies to reach out I
mean we've been having a lot of luck
dial yeah you know we did Russell Brand
respondent he's got come on all right
no we I feel like I didn't we can pull
we can pull pretty high but if it like
someone like Gary spire is a good idea
that's why we saw that big kind of thing
there is like unapproachable I won't
carry Spivey I agree but we can pull
high I bear you a few pockets and as I
see people suggest of that like we don't
really we would love to have them but oh
well some people we've tried like Eric
Andre I've tried yeah we always suggest
the same wine I mean I want Eric Andre
house as much as you guys do but just
know that to where account that keeps
saying a little nice I invited little
[ __ ] he followed me on Twitter I was
like cool and I I asked him if you want
to come on he didn't answer so I'm just
gonna I'm not gonna obviously keep
pushing it that guy dedicated man he's
on every post with a customized icon
that says get a little nozzle on the
podcast if we ever do get him on I'm
gonna credit him we'd have to I like
little knows though all right he's a
character man he seems like more than
anyone he's enjoying his success you
know Billy Irish would be awesome mm-hmm
she has Tourette's we have so much in
like that's such a thing to have in
common
I've never had a conversation with
anybody about that come on that's a lot
to you guys make fun of my textile no
[Laughter]
but Billy Eilish would be great
you know they just come up sometimes and
sometimes it makes sense and I asked all
right let's ship we got we have to go to
Teddy fresh and do work now it's
never-ending
okay how long are we gonna be there
today I'm just gonna have a meeting or
is immortal hours probably a few hours a
few wait it's already two o'clock how
are we gonna be there for a few hours
what's a few tomorrow Donna he was like
three or more we have to leave by 4:30
don't worry your mom is with dinner I
can't be there so far I can't I wish we
took the crisis no it's not good don't
end it
I'm a bi well cuz I'm just so beer maybe
you can / it's my car
it is your cart we should take it to
start overthinking a few hours and souls
off I could really talk we're doing that
Vin Diesel my throat is holy throne like
it writ legitimately heard you need to
exercise
why are you so tired I just performed
for to over two hours didn't mean did
you see Shakira on the Super Bowl I'm
sure she was tired as well fine but did
you see the performance this that I saw
it so what I'm not impressed
try hosting a podcast for two hours
twice a week
I'm super impressive what do you want
I'm not I'm not doing a song and dance
I'm mentally exalt I was prepping why
late into the night last night I've been
doing Vin Diesel impressions all day
let's stop all right well let's go see
what we can do and then hopefully it
won't be that 3:30
no because we have the meeting what and
you have to do design or you have to do
the design stuff we have a top-secret
something going on that I can't mention
but it's super super super super
exciting excitement levels on this thing
I can't talk about one to ten ten yeah
it's a ten it's [ __ ] epic nothing you
guys will see for a long time but the
one that they're gonna see soon is
pretty awesome oh we can say what it is
now spongebob
Club super cool I was happening and it's
coming out in two weeks yeah I guess two
weeks it's coming out on the 27th right
yeah if that thing is gonna sell so fast
because it came out really good and we
didn't get as much quantity as we should
have for some reason but it came out
great
like it's a really good collab really
exciting no I think that's why we're all
so tired it was really hard working on
that one cuz it's like the new one or
the old one
spongebob yeah there's so much in
preparation and like working with this
big corporations have to approve like
every little thing yeah oh my god by
anyway it's been worth it once we're
used to the process it won't be so bad
and we have we're getting more people
and more processes in place so it'll be
easier in the future the first one's
always the most tedious but this one
this new one I mean spongebob is is a
licensing deal this one is a straight-up
collab with what do you say the
difference well so a licensing deal is
that we're paying a royalty to spongebob
mmm-hmm for using their intellectual
property in our designs okay but this
one is a collab in that it's like
working together on designs and
production I mean it's a it's a full
through through collab cut yeah with one
of the I I don't want say that and but
we're burning the candles on both sides
helos up very late working hard on Teddy
fresh daddy fresh daddy fresh and
Theodore was in there with markers he
wants to touch all my stuff and draw
with me I cannot wait
get your act together Mitsy was saying
that there's um you can get like baby
markers that are toys yeah do that yeah
that sounds really cool I cannot wait to
draw with him cuz it's gonna be so fun
he's gonna love it
he's gonna be awesome little artists and
they come up with all this crazy stuff
cuz their house can't wait
all right onto our on to our second job
for a few hours apparently so work
Bethan
[Music]
it's two o'clock right now you keep
explaining our workday starting the
outro music for the second time trying
this again oh ok bye everybody Paul
Newman
[Music]